e
e e
L good morning everyone and welcome to
the house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several bills uh and we have a couple of
bills and a couple of uh house
resolutions scheduled for consideration
today but before we get to those I'd ask
you to please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge of allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all thank you
everyone first bill to be considered
this morning is House Bill 732 FN and
I'll recognize the prime sponsor
representative Glenn cordelli rep
welcome representative cordelli uh thank
you uh Mr chairman and uh committee
members it's a pleasure to be before
this committee uh for the record my name
is Glenn cordelli and I represent tuon
buror wolfboro and oapi in the beautiful
Lakes
Region uh House Bill
732 is really about parents rights and
transparency it's about parents being
aware of the risks associated with drugs
that are being prescribed to their
kids this is about psychotropic
drugs and as indicated in lines six and
seven of the first page um this is
already defined in statute uh and I'll
read that to
you they are a drug prescribed by a
licensed medical practitioner to treat
illnesses that affect psychologic iCal
functioning perception Behavior or
mood risks associated with some of these
drugs include addiction suicidal
ideation aggression and
hallucinations parents should be aware
of the potential benefits and re and
risks in what is being prescrib to their
children that is the intent of this bill
the requirements are very
simple parents have to be presented with
the fdaa F excuse me FDA medication
guidelines for the medication that the
physician is suggested to be taken by
their child under Medicaid why Medicaid
it is State and federally funded and
schools are doing billing for services
under
Medicaid um and what are these
guidelines uh the Federal statutes
Define under 21 CFR
20820 the FDA guidelines and what are to
be included in the guidelines um handed
out uh for your um uh inspection is a
sample um FDA guideline for uh
riddling and in section five you'll see
the warnings and precautions about um
risk to patients abuse misuse addiction
those are the types of things that we
want parents to be aware
of and these federal guidelines um for
the uh for the guidelines um are very
detailed even to the um font size that
these guidelines have to be printed
in
and this legislation requires that
providers prescribing these drugs to
miners review the FDA guideline for that
medication with the parent and obtain
their written
consent knowing the risks and potential
side effects of the
medication um I'll just mention also
that
dcyf under their rules monitors and
oversees the use of these drugs for
children who are in out of the home
placement parents whose children are at
home should have the knowledge to know
the risks and side effects so that they
can oversee the use of these drugs by
their child if they so choose to have
them taken by their
child uh also passed around um are a
couple of letters of support um they
tried to mail them to the committee but
uh they got bounced back for some
reason and uh point out that one of them
is from the consumer representative on
the FD FDA drug advisory
committee this legislation will not take
effect for another year so it gives
everyone plenty of time uh to prepare um
and um become familiar with the FDA
guidelines um there is um a link that I
can mail you if you can choose um that
you can go to from the FDA that will
then show you all the guidelines that
are available and have them available on
PDF
format um so let me just close by
repeating that this is about the rights
of parents to be aware of the risks uh
possibly associated with the medication
that is being
prescribed and about
transparency and I thank you very much
for your time and attention thank you
uh representative
wber thank you so much and thank you for
taking my questions just so I understand
what we're talking about what you are
contemplating is if a provider was going
to prescribe rlin to a child this is the
document that they would need to present
to the parent and and go over and then
document that that had happened is that
correct that is correct okay thank you
um yeah I'll leave representative Woods
U thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question which I will have
some follow on on um um the first one I
have on my list is um um is there any
need to mention uh that uh uh that often
times medication is prescribed for 3
months and then they're doing well then
they're off for another 3 months or so
need to go back on the
medication uh does this uh require that
uh review to occur
again
um the the my reading is so if if um if
I understand your question correctly if
um they're prescribed to take it for 3
months 6 months or something um but then
later on um The Physician feels that the
child needs to go back on that
medication
um yes I would see um there's nothing um
in here that says that they don't have
to do that um process again go over the
risks with the parent and get consent
again oh would there follow so that
leaves a little question about exactly
when that is necessary on the part of
the provider they've been on it before
they've explained it before so there's a
question there um the second um it
mentions a parent or legal guardian uh
often times uh uh kids that have mental
difficulties are not with a parent or a
guardian are living with ant or
grandmother uh or something along that
line uh also some of them are in uh
incarcerated uh and not available to uh
and or in a a psychiatric facility uh
how are those uh I mean um they they
would be handled um uh by
DCF um as I indicated as out of home
placements so if they were in a facility
for instance so there's no impact to to
those
providers um if if they're prescribing
under Medicaid they still um um should
uh
review um the uh medication guidelines
um who with whoever is responsible at
that uh facility
so it's up in the air okay but but the
the basic issue is that dcyf is to
monitor uh that so uh I I I would expect
that in a out of home placement it well
could be the uh dcyf case manager who is
going over um the risks of that
medication with the child because they
are responsible for overseeing uh the
medication so um you all set no go ahead
I'll come back okay representative mlan
and then representative Weber and then
representative
hartnet thank you Mr J thank you for
taking my question so um I'm assuming
and I don't know that there is some kind
of consent currently um so how does this
differ from the current state and and
and what's what what what is the need I
I guess so you have the current state
some need pushed us to a new place and
this fulfills that need so could you
kind of walk us through that right um I
think even um when uh when I go to the
uh uh Walgreens and pick up prescription
for my wife um they ask U if uh would'
like to talk to the doctor um so those
types of things are in place but if if
it's a Medicaid um uh
uh uh involved prescription that's being
provided um we would like this in place
and I think um some of the letters that
um I passed out especially from the uh
consumer um advocate for the FDA um
will'll go into some of the other
aspects of
that that's it follow so so um so is it
is that my understanding then that
currently these discussions can happen
but they're
voluntary uh I I believe that's
mandatory right this would make them
mandatory and having um written consent
to document that um um that uh um
information has been provided and is
understood by the parent one one more
followup and so and so as I read this it
does mandate a a discussion so when
you're saying you know make sure they
understand this is mandating a physical
discussion as well yes thank you
representative Weber and then
representative
paret thank you uh one of uh
representative Wood's questions brought
something new to my mind which is that
in the course of a child being in an
outof home
placement uh it's very often that uh
they are in the course of litigation
about parental
rights and during the entire pendency of
that litigation the parents of course
have their full parental rights and one
of the issues that is very difficult to
deal with in some cases where parents
are not interested in actually pursuing
their parental rights in the way that I
might think they ought to but they
don't um is getting
consent which is required from parents
now uh for all kinds of different things
ranging from a school trip all the way
to important medication decisions so if
DCF doesn't actually have the authority
to give that consent and the parent is
either absent or unavailable or
unwilling to
engage uh what do we do then if the
child is in need of an
intervention and for example DCF also
believes that the child is in need of
intervention um I I think that that is
um an issue
um U with the DCF and their involvement
with the case um I'm I'm not familiar um
directly with uh DCF procedures um in
that case um so I uh can't accurately uh
provide you an answer for that but um I
think that uh um if the parent is not
exercising uh parental
um responsibility or authority um and
dcyf is involved then DCF excuse me DCF
would um oversee the medication uh
prescription H would you understand the
need that there might be a need there
for a clarification because currently
they
can't um I I right I if uh if you feel
that clarification is needed in that
regard I uh I would not object and
um yeah whatever you feel is necessary
um to uh uh you my intent is I I want if
this is Parental involvement with the
child I I want them to be aware of what
the risks are and that's you know my
main intent if you need a clarification
on a few points um I have no problem
with that
representative Weber and not to beat a
dead horse but let me beat it one more
time anyway um the concern that I have
is on the one hand parents whose
children have been removed from their
care continue to have their parental
rights so this bill for those
parents uh runs into the concern that on
one hand there are parental rights which
are protected under the dcyf statutes
that you are
proposing to
limit in some way that is still not
particularly clear to all of us in this
statute
um if you feel this clarification needed
in those instances um I would be glad to
uh work with whoever on getting that
clarification and putting that into an
amendment representative hartnet thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking the
question bring your microphone a little
closer go uh just had a question why
just uh
Medicaid uh
recipients uh basically it's um both
state and federal funding is involved in
that um and um uh it's felt that um uh
for instance um in statute we have U
Medicare medical providers but Medicare
um really covers the gamut from state
and federal um so we figured that was
the uh best direction to take with that
um initially for this
legislation followup yeah um I'm
assuming that the drive uh to generate
this bill is essentially you think there
needs to be a tightening up of practice
here I'm still not quite getting yeah
why I'm sorry I'm still not quite
getting why it would just be focused on
Medicaid recipients um uh I I think that
there is an effort um in many states um
to tighten up on um uh the prescription
of these psychotropic drugs and make
sure that there's parental um awareness
before uh the medication is prescribed
because of the risks um involved in in
many cases um and so um you I've I've
talked with a number of agencies um
including uh International um agencies
um about this and um work closely with
them on the development of this um
legislation okay all set other questions
representative mlan
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so I just want to follow up
on um representative Weber's train of
thought but I want to flip it up a
little bit so she was asking you
sometimes it is difficult um if the
parents are not engaged to get consent
she talk about you know I just want
consent to send the folks on a field
trip conversely though um uh in your
preparing for this bill are you aware of
instances where there are parent s who
are engaged and are trying to get this
information um that they are unable to
do so and it has not been provided to
them um and and and things are just
prescribed without you know the consent
so it's voluntary right now so are there
instances yes I want to know what's
going into my child and it's frustrating
I just can't do that are you aware of
any of that I anodot anodot I've heard
of uh parents really not being aware of
all the
risks um and side effects um uh of a
medication that's being prescribed and
might not be prepared for um witnessing
some of these fi side effects if they do
occur uh because it's important that
they know what the potential side
effects are so that they can deal with
it follow up thank you Mr chair and and
and pardon my ignorance because my wife
and I never had children but if a school
uh sees an issue where they want to
prescribe and you you brought up ridin
um would that be is that done currently
without notification to the parent at
all or what what's the
or they they notify but they're not
having this level of consent so what
what how is it done right now right I I
believe that they would uh talk to the
counselor talk to the parent about um um
for instance ADHD right um and suggest
them to see a physician um uh there
there is incidentally legislation
pending um to make sure that um uh
prescriptions like that are not being
done um at the school level okay so so
it would be involved with the parent and
then a follow-up discussion with the
parents with the child's physician
correct
currently that is my understanding thank
you any other questions yeah
representative uh representative
representative Weber uh thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking the
question sure um do you know of any
other uh aspects in healthc care where
we
similarly uh dictate how uh a
prescribing process would be
undertaken um uh I've never been on the
Health and Human Services Committee just
on the education committee um but I have
had three children um and uh I am I do
not recall um that um so I'm I'm not
sure um the answer to your question
great on set yeah representative
Weber thank you again um having skimmed
a little bit of the uh
a letter from the
FDA
um uh Advocate it says the FDA develops
medication guides to communicate these
potential dangers in clear consumer
friendly language now if I read from
what you handed us one of the points
that they're supposed to look for is
peripheral vasculopathy including Ray
noes phenomena on careful observation
for digital changes is necessary during
R ridd and treatment further clinical
evaluation EG Rheumatology referral may
be appropriate for patients who develop
signs or symptoms of periphery
peripheral vasculopathy do you agree
that that's a user friendly
language um
uh it depends on the
user um but uh I think that that would
be
uh a point that the physician would be
discussing with the parent um I think
that the main thrust um with the
guideline is um as in section five the
abuse misuse and addiction and other
risks that are listed there and I think
that the uh physician would be uh
perfectly capable of uh additionally um
uh considering a user friendly
language uh this might be user friendly
to the FDA but you know maybe not to
some of
us if I may follow up um if if I may a
suggestion I would make for revision
although I'm not sure I would agree with
it even after that is that somebody
ought to do some work on uh whether for
example the sections about risks during
lactation are appropriate for when
they're dealing with kids um but if this
is what you want handed to a parent do
you think that a parent even with a
physician going over it is actually
going to be able to extract the
information that they know need to know
about risks to their children or is
there a different
format that might be considerably more
userfriendly
um this um document um is an
FDA um
document um I think that with physician
a walkth through um the parent would be
aware of the uh risks um involved and
the potential benefits to their child
thank
you anyone
else saying no one else than thank you
thank you very
much also signed up to speak is David
shney from New Hampshire
Medicaid good morning David chy the
deputy Medicaid director for the State
of New Hampshire um thank you for giving
me the opportunity to testify this
morning um I'm just here at generally
provid some information but um had a
couple comments on the
legislation um I think as written um it
it appears the legislation really only
applies to Medicaid enrolled children
and just for reference that covers about
less than one in four children in New
Hampshire so it's less than 25% so a
providers patient panel pediatric
patient panel um 75% of the the the
patients wouldn't necessarily apply to
this higher standard of informed consent
um and so we have some concerns that it
could create provider abrasion U where
they're treating U Medicaid patients
differently than their other patients um
and and that could create uh access
issues if um providers didn't want to
rearrange how they they practice
medicine just for a smaller portion of
their patient
panel um and access issues create costs
and uh Health outcome concerns for for
our Medicaid kids
um there was also I I noticed um it it
appears to maybe omit some prescribers
of these cyp Tropic medicines um and I
was think the advanced practice
registered nurses are able to prescribe
um psychotropic medicine um but the
reporting of um non-compliance would go
to the Board of Medicine which doesn't
overse
them um and so you know similar concerns
about creating provid confusion as to
who can do what um when and then um
Medicaid also has a unique mechanism
that allows for retroactive enrollment
so someone could get care and then
become Medicaid eligible um or apply for
Medicaid and that enrollment can go back
90 days um and so uh I think one
suggestion for the legislation would be
um to add a mechanism to address that
because the provider at the time of the
prescribing wouldn't know that the the
the patient in the future is going to
become Medicaid enrolled um and then
this this higher informed consent
standard would apply um and in talking
with our our medical director Dr Ballard
who is is not able to be here this
morning but he also referenced um there
may be certain emergency situations
where getting the enhanced informed
consent from the parent isn't
practicable for the the emergency care
that is necessary for the the child um
and then on the administrative side we
had some concerns CU there's no
appropriation and there will be
additional cost to investigate um and
ensure compliance um to then suspend
Medicaid claims and and report to the
the Board of Medicine um but happy to
answer any questions representative
wber thank you so much thank you for
taking my question um in so far as you
know because this may not be your Bailey
Wick could you describe to me what
happens when a child is seen uh um in
the schools under the Medicaid rubric
and how consent is or is not obtained
from a parent for a prescription now yep
so currently there's a Medicaid to
schools program um and that provides
Medicaid coverage for Medicaid services
um that uh uh child enrolled in Medicaid
um would get as part of their IEP or 504
plan um and as part of the IEP process
um parents consent and uh help develop
the IEP plan and 504 plan with the
schools um and if um prescribing of one
of these medications was part of that
care plan or treatment plan um the the
informed consent would would occur at
that that level um the the Medicaid the
schools program is not like a a a clinic
within a school just for for Medicaid
kids it's it's specific to um you know
IEPs 504 plans um so more of that that
special education um the medical
component of that special education
piece could
I thank you and I'm just trying to
understand how that program works so uh
in the case of a child who had a 504
plan or an IEP that suggests that they
need psychotropic medication in order
for them to be able to fully participate
in their educational plan at school
would they be
seen in the school or in a physician or
other provider's office I assume that an
advanced practice nurse practitioner
might be the provider that they would
see I think in in many cases they would
be seen by their s in a primary care
practice outside the school for the
prescribing of that medication um I
think the I or 504 plan that is
consented to would you know be about
administering that drug if it would need
needed to be administered um at school
um but there are some clinicians that I
think do come to the school um and if it
was if that was a part of it I guess it
could be but follow followup and in all
cases where a child would be
seen by a provider for evaluation and
prescription of psychotropic
medications would the parent not be
required right now to give their
informed consent to that
treatment yeah um with any medical
treatment informed consent is an
inherent part of the process and and for
minors it has to come from the parent or
legal
guardian and I I did have one other that
goes in a different direction it if if
one of the things that somebody decided
was
necessary was that there was a
disclosure that didn't look like this
but that was actually written in more
plain English uh because I have 20 years
of formal education and I can't read
this
um would there be a cost to the
department if the department was
designated as the agency to develop
those
materials uh I I think it would depend
on the scope of the Department's
involvement um there would be you know a
resource cost to develop the material
but if the department had to print it
and mail it and provide it to providers
that that would be you know another cost
thank you representative
merer thank you Mr chair so in reading
this bill I just see that it's requiring
providers to take an extra few minutes
to provide some FDA information
including some risks which I think are
very
important so I'm still failing to
understand maybe you can help me um I'm
asking the question question of why this
would be a bad
thing I'm not saying it's necessarily A
A Bad Thing um it's just that it's
specific to Medicaid and it's not
specific to all all children that a
provider would treat um so the provider
will have to do something different that
for Medicaid patients than they do for
all of their other patients um and and
Medicaid is a small portion of any
provider's patient panel um just on
average in New Hampshire it's it's less
than one in four
children awesome representative mlan
thank you Mr chair I could ask two
questions sure thank you for taking my
question so the first question uh again
following up on representative Weber
with respect to presenting something
that is more understandable uh to the
parent is what's provided because this
whole thing is very complex I agree but
the actual medication guide called for
in the bill I believe is just the final
page of this handle right so they
wouldn't be looking to digest all of
this which I agree is very complex but
the medication guide for discussion
asked for in the bill is just this final
page right so just is that so would we
want to be is is that clear enough or
would you want to maybe modify that
further um I may ask our Pharmacy
director to help um cuz she to help
answer that question I think she has a
little bit more experience in the
FDA sure she wants to come up
sure hi Margaret Clifford I'm the
pharmacy director for New Hampshire
Medicaid um I don't have the handout
that you have in front of you can
everyone hear okay
no you okay
you need to have the mic right in front
of you so the handout has the FDA
document but I don't believe the whole
of the document is what's required to be
shared just the medication guide at the
back and I just wanted to clarify
that
okay you just shut it off okay I didn't
I thought red might be off
um yeah it would just be the last
section okay thank you and then and then
my second sure my second question thank
you Mr chair so my second question is um
you did bring up some concerns if this
bill were to be
Revisited um where and because I was
kind of thinking since it was going
through the schools everybody whether
you on private insurance or not was kind
of going through that Medicaid rubric
but I think represent Senator Weber's uh
questioning has kind of clarified that
for us so if we were to number one make
it an across theboard requirement and
not just caring out Medicaid and number
two go back to your other concern which
was with respect to arpn if it goes back
to the Board of Medicine arpn are not
accountable to the Board of Medicine so
basically revisiting the reporting
structure if we were to address add
those two issues with the bill does that
address the bulk of your concerns or um
are there other things that are still
kind of hanging out there uh you're
nervous about the only uh there are two
other one is the the retroactive
enrollment um just unlike primary
Insurance where you you're you uh don't
get coverage until you're enrolled in
Medicaid you could see a provider and
then uh apply for Medicaid become
Medicaid enrolled and that Medicaid
coverage can retro back up to 90 days
okay um so it would cover um that
portion so just having a mechanism well
I guess if it applies to all all kids
universally that's actually not not
wouldn't wouldn't be an issue that would
be if it would just applied to Medicaid
so um sorry um but just the emergency
situations exception um and then I do
know this would create some cost or
resources to DCF and I think um that
that's already been raised and getting
dcf's input on on that would
thank you both for the
clarification representative
Drew under what circumstances would one
emergency prescribed Brin do you
know I I don't know um but I don't have
a medical background but it was
something our medical director um
brought out but he's unfortunately out
this week
um anyone
else saying no one else okay thank you
no one else has signed up to testify on
this bill does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on HB 732
FN um and uh we are next schedule to
hear uh HR 16 at 10:30 so we will be in
recess until
then
for
e
e e
good morning everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and L yeah elderly
Affairs um the next uh item for our
consideration is house resolution number
16 I'll recognize the uh Prime sponsor
representative Jack Flanigan from
Hillsboro County District 45
thank Mr chairman and you're taking all
of my
speech um I was asked by former members
of the house that are behind me and the
audience that are going to testify to
submit this resolution to to support and
also um basically provide some platform
for people to know um how hard they
worked during the co pandemic and you
know over time we have and let me let me
preface that by saying I come from a
family of healthc care providers nurse
my mother was a nurse my father was a
dentist and believe it or not that's
Healthcare and my uncle who's still
alive was a retired surgeon um so
there's a health care background in me
um but what happens is over time I think
we tend to forget how bad covid-19
really was especially during its initial
exposure to the public that people I
have friends that have died from covid
um but and unfortunately it was before
the uh immunization process came out so
you know God Rest his soul Bob Burger
but um I think the thing is that over
time we forget how deadly that virus
really was uh and having healthc care
providers
working during that part you know
unknown whether they're bringing it home
to their families and things like that I
think it's important that we basically
have a you know a resolution from this
body saying how much we thank them and
how much we uh really appreciate the
work that they did where a lot of people
just wouldn't do it and with that I'm
going to defer any further testimony to
the other two representative uh The
Honorable Representatives um to talk
about maybe some of their experiences
but I'll answer anybody's question too
because everybody knows me here knows
that I'll answer a question that someone
may come from my testimony
okay thank you are there any questions
for representative
Flanigan not seeing any you're letting
me off the hook we're letting you off
the hook I always appreciate it thank
you also signed up to speak is former
representative Lyn blankenbecker
I
got hi good morning Mr chair Mr Vice
chair honorable members of the health
and human services and elderly Affairs
committee thank you so much for the
opportunity to um speak on what I think
is a very important resolution today uh
I stand in support of this
resolution so um I've been a nurse in
New Hampshire since
1993 but I've never served um in this
capacity for any recognition at all uh I
earned the title of RN which I'm very
proud to have had my entire career and I
take great pride in caring for people at
arguably the most uh vulnerable times of
their lives um I love my time as a nurse
I'm now retired I finally retired from
nursing but I love my time as a nurse
and I found my experiences with my
patients and their loved ones um and in
my community to be most rewarding during
the covid-19 pandemic um that was a very
difficult time as you all know for our
nation and for our state especially for
our healthcare workers all of our
Frontline workers and that's not just
nurses it's doctors nurses dentists you
know ancillary services our EMT
everybody um and it was for many reasons
the logistics made it very uh difficult
to care it made it almost nearly
impossible from lack of supplies to
inconsistent and oftentimes
contradictory guidance from the CDC and
our state and our national government
as to what the rules were regarding care
delivery um and those were ever changing
nurses as a nurse we were required to
use innovation we were inquired to use
Ingenuity anything we had in order to
properly address the health care needs
of those we served fear was another big
issue and it was crippling patients were
afraid and they presented questions that
nurses as that I couldn't answer for the
first time which was you know a very
uncomfortable place to be as a nurse and
not being able to answer
questions that your patients or their
family members may have had some
healthcare workers were so paralyzed
with fear that they opted to shelter at
home and that created critical Staffing
shortages during this time and um and we
had a very exhausted Workforce during
that whole period National fear created
a situation of lockdown of our hospitals
which separated families from their ill-
loved ones and that only increased the
fear and anxiety across this country
with respect to co yet nurses doctors
ancillary staff First Responders and all
other healthcare workers bravely served
knowing that they could become ill with
covid themselves and knowing that their
days would carry extra stressors that
were evolved around Staffing s shortages
limited resources additional testing
isolation requirements and most
importantly our patients with
exacerbated fear and anxiety related to
the isolation and the
separation but we still stepped up we
stepped up and we provided compassionate
and understanding uh care all while
fighting an invisible enemy and adapting
to almost daily new mandates to our care
delivery in my 36 years as a civilian
nurse and as a military nurse I cared
for people and their loved ones in every
situation good and bad I've delivered
babies which is a very happy time and
I've also provided care and a
battlefield in the war zones I've
responded when our community has needed
me and I served aboard the UNS Comfort
when it went to New York City and
provided Co relief to a city that was
especially hardhead um I in fact got Co
on that ship and and understand the
isolation as I was um quarantined for
over a month as a result of Contracting
covid while I was on the ship when I
returned from New York City I was
working as a prosecutor in Hillsboro
County but I also
recognized um that I'm also an attorney
but I um
also they don't put nurses as
prosecutors I probably should have
clarified that uh but I also recognized
that our community um really desperately
needed nurses so Monday through Friday I
worked as a prosecutor for Hillsboro
County and then on Saturdays and Sundays
I worked at a nursing home to provide
care there because they were desperate
for
nurses
um my clinical skills were put to good
use but it was my human skills that
mattered the most um
the nursing home facility that I worked
in like I said it had huge shortages and
because at that time uh the rules were
families couldn't be with their elderly
family members in these
facilities um I sat with a lot of people
who died and they would have died
otherwise alone but the sad part of that
was that those folks died without their
family with them and I became their
family for that short period of time um
I don't think that brought much comfort
to anybody it didn't bring Comfort to
the families for sure who couldn't be
with their loved one to say their final
goodbyes it didn't bring Comfort to the
patient to not or the resident to not
have their family member with them and
it certainly didn't make me feel good
knowing that I was the only person that
was going to be there with them during
this time that was because of policies
where we just were allow were not
allowed to have family members with
their p with their uh loved ones as they
were
dying um um but that was a standard of
care and those experiences have what are
what have left indelible marks I think
on our health care providers across this
state especially and our nation during
that most scary and uncertain
time um so as I stated at the beginning
of my testimony I don't need personal
recognition for my service to our state
or to my nation um during the covid
pandemic and all and all of the response
efforts however I believe this
resolution
is a positive gesture by our state that
validates the hard emotions that
healthcare workers experienced during
the pandemic and it provides um a state
understanding of those difficult days
that we all endured and offer some
healing for those of us who experienced
a whole gabit of feelings at a time when
healthc care delivery in our history was
uncertain chaotic filled with fear
everchanging and the rules um dominated
our personal and professional lives so I
thank you for the opportunity to share
my thoughts today uh I hope all of you
uh who experienced Co in a way that is
unique to you and your families had
positive outcomes for you I know it was
a tough time for all of us and I would
urge you to consider a vote in support
of hr16 because I do think um it's a
collective giant hug from the state of
New Hampshire to those on this 5-year
anniversary believe it or not it's been
5 years since all of this started um
just to recognize and say thank you for
your service so with that um I'll answer
any questions are there any questions
for representative blanken
Becker representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I mean I think
everybody recognizes that the
contribution of our healthcare workers
through covid was Herculean um I I'm
just wondering with this
resolution um how how is it going to be
communicated I mean how how are going
how are people who serve during that
time even going to know that it exists
um and so so I guess we approve it where
does it go from here thanks for that
question so obviously it'll be get right
on the house floor um I hope the media
will cover it and so it'll get sent out
that way there's a lot of organizations
here lobbyists the Ana the American
Nurses Association the American Medical
I'm sorry not the American the state
Nurses Association the State Medical
Association you've got your state EMTs
paramedics your First Responders
associations all of them have a
legislative uh liaison who will be
tracking any kind of legislation or HRS
that come out they should be conveying
those back um good news stories I mean
today we don't have a lot of good news
stories every time you turn on the TV or
every time you open the paper you don't
get a lot of really good news stories
and so when there is a good news stories
I I I feel like we're unique in the
state of New Hampshire that that gets to
be a headliner and so I would hope that
the local papers and that the local TV
stations and radio stations would also
recognize when they're uh broadcasting
about legislation or about activities
that go on in the house that they'll
broadcast that um I was a member of the
New Hampshire Nurses Association and so
these types of things would get shared
with us down the road you know down down
the
line thank you anyone else any other
questions okay thank you thank you so
much and thank you guys for each of you
for what you do every day I know that
you guys are all working on what you
believe is in the best interest of our
state I know how hard it is to sacrifice
your time and your talents to be able to
help us so thank you so much for what
you do as service I know it's not a very
highly paid job
thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Henry Gasson gas gason
I'm
sorry thank you Mr chair honorable
members of committee so I want to speak
in support of this um from somebody who
actually was a responder you guys know a
little bit about my experience and what
I what I witnessed so at the time the
covid-19 pandemic broke out I was
actually the uh excuse me I was the
operation Sergeant for the 101st
Engineer Battalion Massachusetts
National Guard I'm a New Hampshire
resident I was working for
Massachusetts and that first few weeks
it was all hands- on Deck to build field
hospitals in every concert Stadium venue
every place that we could find and then
coordinate with other agencies with FEMA
with local hospitals Etc on how they
were going to be staffed if hospital
system was overwhelmed you know after
that it became massive coordination with
healthc care providers including trying
to uh fill in some of their gaps we you
know had a uh we had a a veterans home
where the whole staff got Co and we had
soldiers pretending to be healthcare
workers trying to staff that home
healthcare workers were working multiple
shifts back to back you were either sick
at home or you were you were at work
there was no vacation there was no rest
cycle there was infinite overtime
whether it was funded or not you were
either you you were either sick or you
were at work and if you were working a
double or or even a triple even though
that's not legal that's where you were
because that's where the people needed
you to be um there were medical
providers that were covering shifts that
were not in their specialty you may have
had a niku nurse covering uh trauma
because that's where the need was at
that time so there was a lot of uh there
was a lot of crossplay among healthc
care providers just to fill in the gaps
and that led to extensive family
separation and extensive burnout as well
I actually have an acquaint who was an
EMT for 15 years going into the co uh
pandemic and then afterwards um that
person left their trade to go back to
college because they were developing
PTSD from being in an ambulance all the
time so if if this is a small thing that
we as a state can do to recognize the
people that took that the brunt of that
Force you know head on whether they
whether they were ready or not cuz no
one is ever ever ready for that kind of
operation then I recommend that we pass
this resolution thank you for your time
thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Ellen Reed from
Rockingham 10
thank you Mr chair thank you honorable
members for the record my name is Ellen
Reed I represent Rockingham 10 new
market in
newfields um this is obviously a
no-brainer I think I can't imagine
anyone being opposed to uh this
resolution but I want to honor the
testimony that came before me of people
who saw the situation on the ground
firsthand of healthare workers during
that time I am not a healthcare worker
no one in my immediate family or in my
immediate friends are healthcare workers
so I am not going to speak to that
aspect I trust everything that has been
told to me about what it was like um I'm
going to speak to the perspective of
someone being in office during that time
because me and I think only a couple of
people here actually were serving when
covid became the thing that we all um
learned it would be so just generally in
our culture we give a lot of Praise a
lot of Praise um and often rightly so to
Law Enforcement Officers to uh veterans
who've served because these are people
who we acknowledge are risking their
lives for the
public we almost never give that level
of praise and certainly not the level of
um benefits freebies discounts to
healthcare workers for their service but
this pandemic highlighted the fact that
they indeed do risk their very lives um
just on the numbers I quickly Googled
um, 1500 healthcare workers died
directly during the the phase that was
the pandemic of uh Co they contracted in
service a 100,000 that's across the
country I don't have New Hampshire
specific numbers 100,000
worldwide so I think it's extremely
important to um acknowledge that these
people were in fact risking their lives
and in fact this was a time that as a
legislator there was a lot of talk about
who was essential and who was not
essential
in in so far as their occupation goes
and I would argue heavily that at any
time healthcare workers are one of the
most essential professions that we could
possibly have more essential even than
law enforcement more essential even than
uh National Defense which I'm not saying
those aren't essential I'm saying that
if you don't have people surviving if
you don't have people who can stay alive
there's nothing to defend and there are
no laws left to enforce so to my
perspective um we were we were declaring
all these different people essential
non-essential what have you we we sent
grocery Baggers to work some of whom
were actually elderly um which is
another social commentary that can be
made um during that time as essential
workers you know who wasn't essential
apparently and this is where I'm going
to get a little bit maybe controversial
we apparently weren't we weren't we I I
contacted the speaker's office so many
times for three solid months begging
pleading please please can we please
meet can we do something about this
terrible pandemic we abdicated all of
our
responsibility we took the sacred Duty
that we were entrusted with by being
voted into office specifically for when
we needed to do something for the people
like that and we just said no too
dangerous for us but we made sure all
those other people went to work and we
didn't and that bothered me deeply at
the time and not only did not act on
that terrible crisis that was happening
we didn't even do our regular job 700
bills died because of an action because
we blew by the deadlines and didn't do
anything about it we just put our hands
in there an entire one of the three
branches of government just said nope
we're not doing it so I think healthcare
workers deserve a lot more than a
resolution a lot more but at the very
very least we can give them a resolution
telling them that yes what we were not
willing to do not even a little bit you
all were willing to do times 100 so that
is my perspective as a non-healthcare
worker at the time and um I don't know
what questions you could possibly have
but I'm happy to take them are there any
questions not seeing any thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is former
representative Warner horn
H H
yes representative horn actually I think
was the um this was your idea right you
had called me and you called
representative Flanigan so thank you for
bringing this to
us uh good morning Mr chairman you are
of course correct members of HHS and EA
kind of a long title for the record my
name is Warner
horn I want to thank you for considering
the house resolution today and as some
of the previous speakers have touched
on five years ago this March 16th we
shut New Hampshire
down we divided up our population
between essential and non-essential
workers and we didn't ask permission we
just told you you're essential go do
your
job and when you have movies being mad
about being made about veterans when you
have movies being made about law
enforcement there PR just few movies
being made about Frontline healthcare
workers and to the good representative's
point we might intellectually be aware
of the
sacrifices
but my concern and the reason for this
is we need to explicitly State how
grateful we are that these people made
the ultimate sacrifice in some cases the
national statistics
100,000
plus I can't I can't imagine what
families went through in New Hampshire
who had Frontline healthcare workers
become sick and die because somebody
declared them
essential I want to make sure that the
politics that went into this covid
crisis aren't affected by this this
isn't about politics this isn't about
right or left this is about the fact
that
when you step up answer the call
Sacrifice by passing by getting sick and
Contracting long lifelong
illness you need to know that that was
important you need to know that that was
recognized and one of the mechanisms we
have in New
Hampshire are the house
resolutions the house has an
opportunity to establish their position
on the sacrifices made by the Frontline
healthcare
workers I had I was in office I was on
my County's nursing home
subcommittee I had a front row seat to
some of the stories that were coming out
stories you've heard from previous
speakers people who were gathered
outside the window of a loved
one and when you had nursing home
workers who were seeing that kind of
misery firsthand on a repeated basis
that's not necessarily what they thought
they were getting into when they applied
for those positions that you would be
declared
essential that most supports that they
had depended on would be evaporated that
Staffing problems
would complicate your position in ways
nobody could have
anticipated for those reason reasons I
would urge the passage of hr19 hr16 send
it to the governor's desk so that New
Hampshire can send a clear and
unambiguous
signal that this is something we care
about that the people who sacrificed
during the covid
crisis are recognized and valued and
with that I'm happy to answer
questions there any
questions thank you for your
consideration
no one else has signed up to testify on
this uh resolution does anyone else wish
to
testify seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on
hr16 uh the next uh item for our
consideration is house resolution 14 and
it's scheduled at 11:30 will be in
recess until then
yeah
e
e e
appreciate you all being there okay I'll
probably call us to order and
um again thank you representative mcin
for being here uh you are the prime
sponsor of the next item on our agenda
which is hr14
house resolution hr14 and um please
proceed thank you Mr chairman good
morning Mr chairman honorable members
this testimony represents My Views and
the views and interests of my
constituents in graft and 18 and I
believe of healthcare consumers across
the state my testimony is not made on
behalf of any private employer nor
should it be construed to represent the
views of any of my employers I'm
representative Donald McFarland from
Orange and I'm here today because every
Granite data deserves access to
Affordable highquality Health Care not a
system where monopolies drive up prices
and limit patient choices our
constituents deserve a fair and
transparent Health Care system one where
patients are treated equally not based
on whether they have insurance or with
whom but based on their medical needs at
its core hr14 is about fairness and
protecting our communities we've all
heard the stories families struggling to
pay for basic care seniors unable to
afford
prescriptions others who don't even seek
care because they feel they will not be
able to afford it and small businesses
burdened by Rising insurance premiums
these aren't just statistics they're are
friends they're are neighbors and our
loved ones and when healthc care
providers consolidate their power
unchecked these struggles become even
worse patients lose and big corporations
win what hr14 does is simple it calls on
our attorney general to take a harder
look at the ways monopolistic healthare
practices and pharmaceutical practices
are harming the people of New Hampshire
it's not about punishing success it's
about ensuring fairness in a system that
should put Patients First not corporate
profits imagine walking into a grocery
store where the price of milk depends
not on its cost but on who you are one
Shopper pays $3 another pays 15 and yet
another is told they can only buy it if
they agree to a long complicated payment
plan that would be outrageous but it's
exactly how pricing Works in our
Healthcare and pharmaceutical systems
today right now the cost of Medical Care
is not determined by what a service
actually costs to provide nor by Fair
competitive market forces but by opaque
and arbitrary pricing schemes set by
powerful H hospital system systems
patients are charged wildly different
prices for the same procedure not based
on lawful price structuring but based on
who their insurer is or whether they
have insurance at all a privately
insured patient might pay three times
less than someone paying cash a Medicare
patient is charged One Rate while a
self-employed person with a high
deductible plan is charged another a
small business owner might pay an
inflated rate just because they don't
belong to a large corporate Insurance
Network and the same holds true for
drugs the exact same bottle of insulin
from an American manufacturer is sold
for one price in Canada and four times
that price here in New Hampshire an
antivenin in Texas is sold for 20 times
the price which the same manufacturer
obtains for the same product in Mexico
this is not a free market this is price
fixing by Monopoly
power when a patient needs care they
should know what they'll be charged and
they should not be gouged based on who
they are who their employer is whether
they're self-employed or whether they
have the wrong insurance plan the United
States Supreme Court has already ruled
that price fixing schemes like these
violate Federal antitrust law and you'll
see that I have cited two cases in the
resolution let me highlight those cases
for you in group life and health
insurance company versus Royal Drug
Company the Supreme Court ruled that
that Healthcare markets including
insurers and providers must comply with
antitrust laws the ruling confirmed that
pricing agreements designed to exclude
competition are
unlawful in Arizona versus Maricopa
County the Court ruled that medical
providers cannot set fixed
non-competitive prices for different
groups of consumers and it rejected the
idea that Health Care should be exempt
from fair pricing and competition laws
these rulings make it clear Healthcare
is not above the laww hospitals and
insurers cannot create arbitrary pricing
structures that have no basis in actual
costs but are simply designed to extract
the maximum possible revenue from
different patients and as you'll see in
the resolution we have seen that Revenue
increase relative to GDP in ways that
are unacceptable we are seeing healthc
Care at 20% of GDP today and only a few
short decades ago it was at four or 5%
of GDP
I I could go on but I I think that this
committee well understands this problem
and well understands that what is needed
is action by the attorney general and by
the other states Attorneys General and
so I urge your support for hr14 and I'm
happy to yield the questions thank you
Mr chairman thank you any
questions my representative Weber
sorry thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my my question
um I have I I don't disagree with
anything you have said and um you've
given a
great overview of the
problem what I want to know is why you
have chosen to bring this as a
resolution which has no force in law
that's sort of question number one and
if I may just ask the carer
question um if anything is to be
investigated there are associated costs
and of course we do not investigate
costs when there is a resolution but
have you done any investigation about
the costs that might be
involved in doing what your resolution
asks great question uh or set of
questions so let let me respond to those
uh in turn first of all I actually did
start off with this intended to be a
bill and intended to be a bill that
would um not mandate that the Attorney
General uh prosecute certain entities
because that would be uh a a conflict of
you know the the separation of powers um
but at least require certain reporting
from him um and require other actions by
the Attorney General's
office I was not able to to get to a
version of that bill language um
courtesy of OSS that I thought was
viable and I decided that the better
course of action than present to you a
bill that I myself didn't think was in
good order uh was to submit this
resolution this year and hope uh that
the AG respects our point of view and
takes action uh and if that doesn't come
to pass I think that there are other
actions that um this body and the
general court can take uh I will tell
you though that in the course of
preparing that language that that
ultimately I didn't move forward with I
spoke with the Attorney General on a
couple of
occasions um he expressed that he is um
interested and and uh understands the
concern and and I think to some extent
shares the concern although I did not
get ultimately uh any firm point of view
from him as to whether uh he believes
that this is a um a set of problems he
wants to move forward with um but I I
certainly in the course of that uh and
in the course of my conversations with
the legislative researchers talked about
the potential Financial impact in fact
in one version of my draft I had
contemplated making um a a stipulation
about a l in the budget for it and what
I received back was uh strong guidance
that that was unnecessary strong
guidance from both legislative services
and frankly from the AG's office that uh
they are already uh afforded uh the
ability to direct their attention to
where they see fit and I think the
question at hand is whether they should
be looking in this particular direction
and if they do I am sure that in the
course of winning some of these lawsuits
they would be able to recover any cost
they might
have other questions representative
Woods no thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um I
certainly understand the intent and uh
from my personal perspective would
certainly agree uh at the at the face of
it however um would it be uh that in
fact uh there should be directed
uh in a a slightly different direction
by that I mean uh it seems like this
carries the assumption that a
market-based system is the system that
we should work
with um whereas there have been some
questions that if this were healthc Care
were not delivered on a market-based
system that the problems that you've
addressed would in fact go away would
you care to address that I'd be happy to
address that representative and can I
just understand essentially what you're
asking are you asking would we be better
off with a Cooperative
system there's a variety of systems one
of which would be a single
paay
so I mean first and foremost I would say
to you that that is not the basis of our
country and of our
constitution uh either at the federal
level or at the state level uh I believe
in free markets I don't believe that we
have free markets in all cases just as I
described here um but I would also point
you rather than making my response be
based upon our particular points of view
on these things I would point you to the
Supreme Court ruling itself that I
referenced and so you know if I look at
um the the ruling in um the uh sorry one
second here if I look at the ruling in
in group life versus Royal drug right uh
that ruling makes it abundantly clear
that Cooperative pricing is not in fact
lawful under our Constitution and I
think that when you talk about other
structures such as Single Payer systems
they to have profound constitutional
problems other questions rep uh
representative Lucas and then
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here and taking my question um
I'm interested in your um opinion about
um so-called
cherry-picking when um the free
market
um uh results in um facilities that
provide uh care basically to a healthier
better insured population
and then leaving the higher Acuity by
necessary more expensive care to um uh
other facilities that take all comers
thank you so first of all um and if I
may can I just ask you um or ask the
representative Mr chairman are you
familiar with the surgery center of
Oklahoma I'm not okay I would recommend
the committee uh as an example of an
institution that works with strong price
transparency to take a look at the
website for the surgery City of Oklahoma
where they publish pricing for a variety
of
procedures and I grant you that that
particular example is an example of an
institution that does not provide every
possible Health Care
procedure
uh but I think it is instructive when
you look at that to to be able to
compare the pricing for those procedures
that it does service to the pricing for
those procedures that you see from our
hospitals here in state and so back to
your question do I believe that we have
healthc care institutions
today that are increasing the price
arbitrarily on one procedure in order to
subsidize another procedure yes I do and
I find that to be uh in contravention of
our laws both our state laws and our
federal laws and we should be holding
them to account for that that is not to
say that we should not be charging more
for an emergency procedure than for a
procedure which is scheduled a month in
advance in the middle of a weekday but
it is to say that when we have one
person
forced to subsidize
another that in of itself is a violation
of our antitrust laws and I would argue
that the words that we should be using
around that include words like
racketeering corruption and
fraud representative
mlan thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so um it is within
the Attorney General's purview to go and
investigate fraud um you know if it
exists but it's not within the Attorney
General's purview um to maybe go in and
investigate you know the basic structure
um there are other agencies that kind of
do that but if there is fraud it's
definitely um within his purview to go
after it so um but this
resolution kind of
presupposes that a lot of what's
driving um the the High pricing is
indeed fraud antitrust things of that
nature at least as I read it it's kind
of implied in in the findings in in the
resolution so I'm just wondering you
know not knowing for sure that it is
fraud but maybe it is just a structural
problem on what because we we don't just
investigate organizations there has to
be a crime to just so on what basis on
what legal basis um do you think the
Attorney General
can can proceed do you think there is
enough with this to proceed are there
other states um that have gone forward
and and you know we're going to open up
an investigation because yes we think
that it is fraud and so I guess I'm just
I'm I'm asking the question poorly but
what is the ba the legal basis upon
which he could initiate the
investigation um and where do you see
that within this resolution okay so I
think there's a lot of questions that
you asked in there but I I'll I'll try
and respond to the gist of of what I
understand them to be first of all the
Attorney General is not uh unable to
investigate entities before he has
determined that there is a crime that
has occurred to the contrary that's the
point of our judicial system is to
determine whether there's a crime that's
occurred the Attorney General can choose
to investigate based upon uh suspicion
cause and so forth and um not merely a
fraud we have an entire chapter in our
statutes here in New Hampshire that
addresses antitrust law and so what I'm
suggesting in this resolution is not
that out of the gate he should just go
and start Prosecuting people I am
suggesting that he should investigate
and turn some attention to this matter
and if he finds cause to do so then yes
of course he should take action um those
actions
are uh literally what that office does
every day and I don't think that there's
anything in what I'm putting forward
here which limits his ability to operate
um in the way that he would at any other
time
follow thank you very much and that's
very Illuminating um are are you aware
of any other states that have had
similar resolutions and have kind of
gone down this path and have found
anything substantive thank you for the
question yeah I I am aware that since
those Supreme Court rulings came
out we have and by the way they are from
1979 and
1982 we have seen next to no enforcement
of the the outcomes that follow from
those rulings and I put it to you that
the reason we have seen that is because
the healthcare Lobby is strong and has
only been getting stronger and stronger
over the last
decades thank you other questions
representative
Weber thank you so much and thank you
for the Indulgence of another question
and I uh understand your point which is
well taken about matching the actual
costs with the actual procedure does
that mean that you would also support
ensuring that Medicaid was well enough
funded to pay the full amount
of the cost of every procedure that and
service that is rendered to Medicaid
patients so I don't think that's Jermain
to this resolution I'm happy to have a
conversation with you in the cafeteria
about Medicaid and Medicare and in point
of fact I had intended to bring a bill
uh not unrelated to that this year but
again uh I didn't get to where I wanted
with OS but maybe we'll be talking in
another year thank you other discussion
any other questions question
representative taes hi uh thank you and
thank you for taking my question so I'm
a little confused um because uh part of
what I heard you mentioned was uh
different people or payers pay different
rates for the same service but that is
sort of the foundation of how our Health
Care system works right insurers have uh
purchasing power and so they negotiate
different rates for paying so so at
least as far as the the costs of
healthcare paid by insurance or paid by
individuals that seems like an insurance
issue and I'm curious why you wouldn't
be taking it there and and also just it
seems like the most American thing we
have right which is uh business
operating as business
does so I mean first of all uh you say
that our Health Care system works I I
would beg to
differ I think that
what you just outlined is part of the
problem if I pull up at a gas
station I expect to be able to fill my
car for the posted price per gallon I do
not expect to be questioned as to what
car insurance I have or to have my car
looked at to determine whether or not
the color of the car or the the the
model is relevant to changing the price
and so you know what you're talking
about is a model model that is not based
upon proper commercial practices where
for example if I go to a manufacturer
and I say I would like to purchase 100
widgets of X they may give me a discount
versus if I go to purchase one
widget it is certainly cheaper for a
health care provider or anyone
else any other company to sell 100 units
at the same time to the same
person as to sell them individually to
100 different people with 100 different
circumstances and 100 different sets of
invoices and so forth but that is not
the case when you have
insurers uh I know that there are
contracts that are structured to claim
that that is the predicate for some of
this variable
pricing um however that is one of the
the issues that the Supreme Court ruled
against and so I I think that if you
take a look at the case law on this uh
you will find that there is uh a case to
be pursued here and uh look I'm not a
lawyer uh I I believe that the Attorney
General is far more capable of making
those determinations that I am and uh
that our courts are as well and I look
forward to that
happening so my question was it seems
like it should be like an insurance
department issue that was my I yes I I
understand that and I didn't address
that part of your question so um one of
the two Supreme Court cases I referenced
the group life versus Royal drug
uh spoke to the McCarron Ferguson act
which is an act that is related to
Insurance um and so to that extent I can
understand your question saying well
isn't this an insurance issue the
rulings core principle applies broadly
Healthcare markets cannot use
exclusionary agreements to limit
competition and hr14 addresses those
anti-competitive practices uh in a broad
fashion right and and I think that uh
any reasonable interpretation of of the
Supreme Court ruling would understand
that it extends to healthc care
providers and to uh Pharmacy uh
companies as well as it does to
insurers and and by the way the other
ruling uh is predicated upon the Sherman
Antitrust Act and has no insurance
specificity to
it other
questions seeing none okay represent I'm
filing thank you thank you Mr
chairman no one else has signed up to
testify does anybody else wish
to seeing no one else uh that uh that is
the last hearing we have scheduled until
1:00 so I'm going to close the public
hearing on hr14 will'll be in recess
until 1 p.m. at which time we'll hear HB
4:55 you stand in
recess
e
e e
okay um welcome back to the house
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs we have one more uh
item to be discussed today uh and here
in public hearing that is HB
455 the prime sponsor representative
Jess Edwards from Rockingham County
can't be with us this afternoon but
representative Lucy W from cheshier
County will be um introducing the
bill and the chair recognizes
representative
Weber thank you representative Weber for
pin thank you thank you and I
actually was supposed to be on this bill
but life intervened and I didn't sign
off in the right amount of time the bill
came out of reporting which is done to
the Health and Human Services oversight
committee for the the relatively
recently established um
um
enhanced provision of services
for uh pregnant women we extended the
time and we when we extended the time we
also required quarterly reporting on
that
program and I think that the purpose of
this uh legislation is simply to
um repeal the quarterly reporting
requirement as of July first
2025 um
so because it was felt that the program
is established we don't need to have
quite as many reports so uh that's the
entire import of the bill and I would
defer to Mr Lipman on U any questions
you might have but it was a request of
various members of the Health and Human
Services oversight committee thank you
very
much good afternoon Mr Litman welcome
back thank you uh chairman and members
of the committee U Henry Litman State's
Medicaid director and this came out of a
discussion at as was mentioned at Health
and Human Services oversight um the way
the original legislation was enacted it
was a forever reporting I think this is
saying to and I think this actually came
at uh representative Edwards suggestion
was to have some end point of the
quarterly reporting and that is um at
the end of the bium um
2027 and we we supported his suggestion
and would appreciate if you would enact
this okay so the department does support
the bill yes okay are there any
questions for yes representative mlan
representative w
oh I'm sorry all right gentlemen who
wants to go first representative Woods
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this is U just a um
perhaps exposing my ignorance um uh
number two uh uh section two repeals RSA
such and such uh but section one uh
usually it says after such and such
insert the following or da D nothing is
inserted so it almost looks like the
repeal takes place and the reporting is
uh that was there is Del is
deleted but the paragraph above it
doesn't say to insert it in a particular
place and um almost as if it you know it
seems like there should be some
reference to installing that reporting
mechanism in place and I may just be
reading it
incorrectly I believe
believe that the language up at the top
is the existing language of
4D which is what would be repealed and
the reason it's not in bold is because
it's already in
statute uh because if I read 4
D um although it does have a different
date it starts at 2024 so um I'm not
sure about the fact that there is no
reference for insertion on the first
part and I'd be glad to go and check OS
about that I know I have gotten
into muddles before with repeal dates
because you have the statute and then
you have the effective clause and then
you have the repeal dates and they're
all in different places uh I think this
one's okay but I'd be more than glad to
go check on it to make sure it does
here's the RSA that's what's wanted
that's being
deleted um
and and it does not say that section one
replaces yeah that's which I think we
may need yeah that was my
question so I will undertake to find out
about that okay thank or bring it or
bring an explanation for the executive
session you said it more concisely that
some replacing would be
the representative mlan and then
representative
Maser thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so um it looks like
they're going to uh Sunset the report so
I guess what I'm trying to understand is
um is because I'm not familiar with
these quarterly reports are these
quarterly reports common in other areas
um to do TR in and um is it normal that
they just kind of like have a shelf life
and that they sunset uh I'm just trying
to get to you know what is normally the
scope of these corly reports and do they
Sunset so I for the Medicaid Program um
can speak to that what I'm responsible
for I believe right now it's this is the
only report that I have to hh's
oversight that's a required
legislatively so I think historically um
when the postpartum coverage part of the
Omnibus
1.0 um initiative there was interest to
make sure that the department timely
sought the um state plan amendment to be
able to to provide that coverage which
we we did so that was one part of the
report which we can say every quarter
that back in October we got this in 2023
and so that part is really per P that
the part now is to see whether um how
the the benefit is being used and
whether people are getting access to it
and I think you know reporting Forever
on it I think is part of an
issue representative Maser and then
representative Weber yes thank you Mr
chair so kind of following up with what
representative mlan asked is I can see
you know a a a change to the the
reporting not being quarterly but why
not make it at least like once a year or
or twice a year because it correct me if
I'm wrong is is it is it a isn't it
wouldn't it be a worthwhile report so we
do think it's worthwhile to do on a
quarterly basis um for a period of time
as opposed to having a quarterly report
forever if you
will set kind of Representative
Weber uh this isn't actually a question
but I can put in a question if you'd
like me to but I know why it's drafted
this way now I figured it out my guess
is that because section D was a
permanent reporting requirement it was
put in the
statute because what we replacing it
with is a temporary reporting
requirement it would only go into
chapter law it would not go into the
statute and um so what this is doing is
repealing D which is in the statute in
its entirety but the part that isn't
inserted in the statutes in any
particular place becomes part of chapter
law and it's a requirement but chapter
law is used often when it's a temporary
thing that's
happening that doesn't need to be a part
of the statute so that's my guess I will
I will find out about
that right right the law is that which
is boldly asserted and plausibly
maintain so and thank you very much for
taking my question so so I can
understand um you have had other
quarterly reports they have sunsetted if
things have come along and this is the
only one that remains and it like the
other ones is going to Sunset with all
these reports though being sunset
um maybe you're not making reports but
do you have things in place now that are
continuing to track once we go beyond
these sunsets the efficacy of these
programs um and are they reported out at
sometime or this is just data you're
collecting so I'm just trying to
understand what survives beyond all
these quarterly
reports so I think in terms of the
Health and Human Service oversight
committee anything they're interested in
um we come and make a presentation on so
for example um the adult Dental benefit
implementation that's something there
wasn't a required report but it was of
interest to track what was going on and
we report on um the the unwind of
continuous coverage um that was
something that we reported regularly for
a period of time till that was completed
um I imagine if um legislation passes
this session about um you know the
Governor's budget related to um
eligibility or premiums or what have you
that that would be something that they
would expect us to speak to them about
um new waivers um it's really at the
discretion of the chair um uh and the
committee will will report what they we
want to keep them informed the way they
want to be kept informed follow so and
so just to clarify so you're not going
to be making any reports outside of a
request but you are Contin continuing to
gather all the data so that if a
question should Arise at some point in
the future you have access to that data
to generate a report kind of on demand
yeah pretty much I mean I think if they
had something esoteric that I mean what
we're what we're trying to look at here
is you know are women taking advantage
of this um so we look at eligibility and
see people being enrolled and then the
purpose of extending Beyond 60 days to a
year was to make sure that um you know
it's hard to get get medical
appointments done in 60 days in this
environment but you know what types of
services are they being are they
accessing and what results are we seeing
in terms of maternal Mor mortality or or
neonatal mortality that um these types
of services supporting would would would
uh support just as a matter of
background we were one of the earlier
states to adopt this there are now 48
states that have and the two that
haven't are have pending legislation to
to actually add even more than what New
Hampshire
has thank you very much Mr litman's
Point um when we exec the bill on the
ALS registry that's a new issue that
we've asked oversight to look into and
we discussed at our last meeting so to
to Mr litman's Point um they they're
very good about following up AJ uh the
department is about any requests the
oversight committee has representative
Weber and I will ask this one the form
of question isn't it true that when we
stood up the doorways program you
reported um again that was a initially a
Governor's program so it was not in
statute but it's true isn't it that you
reported to the committee the oversight
commission oversight committee once a
month for about two years I believe that
to be true
yeah other
questions I'm seeing none Mr chairman
any anytime this committee would like
any information that you know we're we
want to keep you apprised so you can
make good policy and we we appreciate
all the support this committee has given
in the last number of years to improve
uh eligibility policy and coverages in
New Hampshire so thank you thank
you I want to ask if anybody else wants
to testify uh unless there's somebody
hiding under a table or a chair or
something all be
haunted so with that I will close the
public hearing on HB
455 um there were no other bills or
resolutions before us today uh we do
have a hearing scheduled for next week
and I I again I apologize representative
Weber um a number of you did not know we
were meeting on Monday uh and uh on a
couple of bills that are expected to get
a big crowd that's why they they got put
on their own day
um and then we have an a normal meeting
schedule on Wednesday at which time
there will be some executive session
issues as well any questions before
representative Woods uh yeah um was
there any concern I when I saw the type
of bills uh any concern that they might
be wise to move it to
repol there will be an overflow room too
that was raised and they're they're
trying to
discourage hearings and representatives
Hall yeah cuz I would anticipate I
raised that question myself with with
the staff and so forth
um for a number of reasons they would
prefer to try to do it in a double room
with an overflow room uh also I've given
the nature of these bills we never know
what the nature of the crowd will be the
size of the crowd will be and I've also
expressed some concerns that there' be
security also so in the event it's
necessary not that I expect anyone to be
physically endangered or anything but
just in terms of crowd control and stuff
like that so just a question sure I
expect a big
crowd any U any other questions or if
not I will we'll adjourn and again I'll
see those of you who can make it on
Monday or I'll see you next Wednesday
standard joh
I think I think I think I think I'm okay
with it as long as they keep data which
can be called
for for